[Music]
do you think it's okay to have people
live in these conditions do you think
it's okay to have people live like this
the 8 news now i-team pushing the
manager of a crime-ridden apartment
complex for answers the residents there
living under just awful conditions and
what's more the owners have been taking
your tax dollars now this is not the
first time we've told you about the apex
apartments which are located just east
of the strip as vanessa murphy tells us
the managers keep dodging our questions
the apex apartments are at a busy
intersection here at twain and cambridge
there's a park across the street there's
an elementary school on the corner and
there are other apartment buildings in
the area but look at the condition of
the apex apartments you can see numerous
windows boarded up there are frequently
squatters in here police say it's a
magnet for crime this affects the
neighborhood tenants here and taxpayers
as the eight news now i-team first
reported the owners have been receiving
covid 19 rent relief money now take a
look at this video we've been trying to
interview the owners to get answers but
as soon as we tried to approach a
manager thursday she ran hi you're the
manager for california right
do you think it's okay to have people
live in these conditions this was
shortly after a meeting between apex
apartments management metro police and
clark county commissioner ticksaker
bloom who represents this area
california-based pro-residential
services bought the place in january of
2021 and has been operating without a
license in a previous email to the
i-team pro-residential said it's working
on converting the place from a motel to
apartment use but our requests for an
interview were ignored commissioner
sagerboom and his team have been trying
to avoid shutting it down giving the
owners multiple chances to make repairs
and to make the property safe one
condition have security do you feel any
safer no not at all residents like amy
irwin say the property is still a mess i
don't let my kid outside to play and i
don't even want to walk them to school
within the past week how many times have
you seen security how often are they
there i actually haven't seen security
has anything changed no they just told
us to come to the back door to get our
mail and pay the rent the owners have
also been receiving public money
according to clark county a spokesman
says the county spent more than 326
thousand dollars in the past year to
help tenants there pay back rent you
guys were getting the tax money right
can you answer me
can you answer me you guys are getting
the tax money is that okay for people to
live like this security steps in while
the manager continues to run away and
hide you guys been for a while we just
got hired so
careful
please can you go off property sir the
i-team is escorted off the property can
you guys go ask her if she'll come talk
to you
we can ask them but i'm not sure what
they're going to say but you got to just
come on the sidewalk here the manager
refusing to come out for an interview
now again the county is waiting to see
if the owners cooperate and clean the
place up why so many chances
commissioner saker bloom points to the
severe affordable housing shortage he
also says he wants to make it a crime
for landlords like this to operate
reporting in las vegas vanessa murphy
live local now